So far, we've worked with the numerator being 1. We have only had one piece out
of five. Let's see what else we can do. Here's a square again, and I'm going to
split it up into four parts. Now, instead of having one piece, I'm going to have
three. So now the area of this shaded square is 3 4ths. My numerator is 3,
because I have three pieces. My denominator is 4, because I've split up my
square into four equal pieces. Here's another square, and this time, I'm going
to have all the pieces. Let's see what that looks like. So, now I have 4 out of
4. When I have 4 divided by 4, that's really 1. Now that we've seen that the
numerator doesn't have to be 1, let's try an example where it's not. We'll try
this out with a quiz.